hello everyone and welcome to a wild
game between Magnus Carlsen and Fabiano
Caruana it's a game from around 700 2018
Sinquefield Cup and there's really a lot
at stake in this game if for example
Caruana wins this game then he will
overtake Magnus Carlsen in the live
ratings and if he finishes the
tournament nicely then he might become
the new number one chess player in the
world you know a ratings wise and also
it's a pretty big thing for the
tournament standings Fabiano karana is
currently the sole leader would have a
point ahead of everyone else I went for
Magnus Carlsen I would definitely go
huge for him in this tournament and also
to increase the gap between the ratings
but if this is a even a small taste of
what we can expect in November then it's
November is definitely going to be a
great month so before we check out the
game we do have a nice photo challenge
so in honor of of Kiwanis the defense
who is the gentleman in the photo here
so there you have it the best of luck to
everyone now let's check out the game
cause an opened with e4 and Corona
replied with E 5 so no doubt we will see
the better of defense Knight to f3 and
we do have the petro defense on the
board Knight captures on e5 across and
goes for the classical variation we have
d6 now goes back and now Knight captures
on e4 and now Knight to c3 the names of
its variation and also my favorite
against the Petrov we have Knight
captures the D captures on c3 and now
Bishop to d7 Bishop to e3 nice to see
six Bishop to c4 we have castles and the
now comes Queen to d2 across and
signalizes that he's ready to castle
eater of King sight or queen side
depends on on the mood Bishop to f5 and
here cross and dust Castle queenside and
as you can see we have opposite opposite
castles on the board which means Carson
will want to push his pawns on the on
the King set and attack Corwin as king
and Corona will of course try to do the
same on the Queen side Queen d7
of course Corona wants to prevent
Carlsen from starting to push his
opponents King to b1 safety of the King
first of course and now rook ft8 and
here we have h4 already by Carlson
Bishop to f8 would have h5 and h6 and
here it's a very nice moment in the game
now how do you how do you start to push
your points here and start attacking the
bishop is on a very nice diagonal here
on the f7 pawn you want to push g4 as
soon as possible so what are your
options here as they mentioned in the
live feed and Knight h4 is a very nice
idea attacking the bishop here Knight to
g6 can also be played if depending on
what black plays as the f7 pawn is
pinned but here black can go there
should be six and after characters
captures the black is perfectly fine
here the queen is preventing white from
pushing g4 and you can't really push f3
and then go g4 because your Bishop on e3
would be hanging another thing you can
consider is nice to h2 and then you
prepare g4 or f3 g4 but then you lose
control of d5 square and then which
nicely v and here black really puts a
knight on a beautiful square and now the
position of your Bishop that is
undefended on c4 becomes questionable
and another thing you can do after this
h6 move you can go up to b3 but here
black can simply push a 5 start
attacking this Bishop or even better go
Knight a5 and eliminate the strong piece
so here cross in place a move that was
really praised by everyone especially by
a sir he plays a bishop back to e - yeah
he has to describe this as a carpeaux
bian move or it seems like a bishop was
very active on c4 but in fact it wasn't
as you saw that the knight from i-5
could really challenge it so simply I
moved with the bishop back and now
Carson will prepare perhaps Knight h2
and then starts pushing his pawn
also the bishop from e2 will be also
eyeing the g4 square
so first Corona plays Bishop to g4 now
if the knight is moved a qur'anic at
exchange bishops Knight h2 was played
now cross and attacks the bishop twice
and Bishop captures Queen captures and
here Knight to e5 preparing to bring the
knight over to c4 and it's a very nice
idea because now if course and starts
pushing his pawns carelessly then Corona
can indeed play Knight to a5 would a
double attack on the bishop here and
after an exchange is made here captures
cap
Knight of 3 in the other rook can come
into the game for example C 6 and then
the rook can easily be the drugs can
easily be doubled on the e-file so it
would be a perfectly nice position for
black after 95 Carlsen place another
move that once again impressed everyone
and bush up to c1 a waiting move but you
know later this bishop can really become
a powerful piece Queen to c6 here Bobby
now prepares to protect the night and
preparing Knight to c4 basically but
okay Crossing place f4 we do have Knight
to c4 the c-4 square is guarded now
Queen to d3 and here Queen to e4 here
Fabi wants to exchange Queens
immediately I thought okay perhaps
perhaps even a move like rook to e4
could it could be played it seems like a
very nice move prepares to double files
to double row Conde file but here cross
and can simply start pushing his pawns
on the Kings side after you GG v is
coming and it's a really really nice
setup here for for white captures
captures h6 is coming so a very nice
position for white okay Fabi goes for a
queen to e4 he wants to trade Queens but
Carson ignores him he pushes g4 and he
says if you want to trade Queens you can
capture my queen but then I will under
ball here and my position will improve
very nicely here so kg 4 we have night
to e3 attacking costumes rook on d1 and
now rook d2 e 1 the strongest move
Crossing plays it pretty much instantly
queen capture son v 3c capture son d3
and now Knight to d5 as the night was
attacked twice and repeat the g1 here
also a move that kind of you know moves
away from the principles of chess as
rooks do belong and open files but here
while the rook is any file you can
simply exchange all the rooks and then
you white really won't have anything to
put for advantage with so instead he
goes to rope ether g1 places the rooks
on the G and H file he wants to push g5
open up some of the files and then
pressure the black King and in in this
position cousin had 28 minutes on the
clock while
one had 23 minutes on the clock and it's
only moved 23 so still 17 or 18 moves to
be made for for Carson or Fabia Fabiano
so okay rook to e6 rook to e2 was also
possible but for some reason karana
didn't didn't enjoy it the rook is a bit
more active any - of course but I need
to it's not gonna be an active member of
the of the Kings defensive squad as g5
is coming so okay he goes rook to e6
cross and pushes g5 and here we have
Knight to e7 it seems like King to h7
was a better move here but even after
King to h7 f5 is coming and then it's
really really another pleasant position
for black here Khurana played 9 3 7 and
crossed an immediately grab G chapters
on h6 and it was in this position that
Carson went into the confessional booth
the confessional booth is something
there they're having during the
Grantchester where a player is you know
picked up from the board he goes into
the confessional booth and then he
discusses openly his position so the
viewers can enjoy it something like you
know if you play Texas Holdem you you
know the viewers know which cards the
players have so everything is out in the
open and it's also very interesting
because you can hear what the players
are thinking about and here Coulson just
went you know like hush quiet the haters
as you know stating that he will win
this game you know don't don't interrupt
him and here of course you cannot
capture with the pawn the ponies pinned
Khurana played rook captures on a6 and
everyone was really impressed by this
move I everyone thought King 2h7 would
would be played and Khurana would be
down upon because here f5 it was
expected and it was played instantly by
Carlsen and now you run into a lot of
problems here for example if you capture
here you lose the game Knight to g4 and
you're lost for you capture rook rook
afters on h1 and now you don't recapture
immediately barrette or Knight to f6
check the point is of course pinned you
cannot capture you cannot go to h7 you
have to go to 88 and now rook captures
on each one will be checkmate on the
other hand
Knight to g4 even if you don't capture
on each one you could capture the pawn
for example but still you get Knight to
h6 check the point isn't getting pinned
I you have to move the King Knight
captures an f5 opens up a discover to
check you move the King captures
captures you're done a whole rook white
is completely winning so Corona
calculated precisely he played a rook to
h7 and here after some consideration
Carlsen played nice to g4 Knight to g4 a
move that will cost him dearly later as
if you've seen the live coverage you
know what I'm talking about if you
haven't I suggest you check it out it
was really a thriller here Knight to g4
he thought that wins he thought this
wins the game but instead it was f6 that
would have most likely won him the game
if Corona didn't play like I don't know
20 injured moves in a row because after
this move of course the g1 is still
pinned let's say 95 now comes Knight to
g4 and now unlike the variation that
happened on the board
the knight is misplaced here on d5 and
the king is ng8 not on a on the h-file
as you'll see later here g6 see for
kicking the knight even further back
Knight b6 now comes HG address on g6 and
now it all depends what do you play if
you play F captures then you get to rook
captures King captures and f7 now the
rock is coming to f1 this pawn on f7
will be guarded Bishop is coming all the
way to c3 the control is diagonal and
it's most likely most likely now black
will be will get crushed here on the
other hand after H captors on g6 you
could go for rook captures on h1 but
this simply loses upon his Black has
this addition to or an in-between move G
captures on f7 with check King
characters and only narrow characters on
h1 which leaves white with an extra pawn
but here Carson did not find after 97
this sorry this f6 move
he played Knights the g4 not now f6
immediately so Knight to g4 was played
and here Corona played
came to h8 Carlson did play f6 now and
now nice the g8 was played and it was in
position that cousin realized that okay
there's really no breakthrough here and
he really spent a lot a lot a lot of
time here and not only that one of the
reasons as he said later in an interview
with Maurice one of the reasons he
played 94 and not Knight to f6 isn't
because he didn't see this line he
didn't see an idea after Knight to f5
the knight from fi will now be defending
the g7 pawn but although there is no
clear refutation of the night.the Knight
to f5 move simply rook to g5 attacking
the knight but then Knight comes to h6
and well the idea is that blacks
position is really funny and the dead
white is better this is basically it but
and Carson said he found the refutation
against Knight a5 after he played the
Nigerian mind after that I have no idea
but ok at 5 roof to h7 and 94s was
played knocking h8 and we have f6 but
now Knight the g8 and here the game
continues here Carson really spent all
of his time as he was a much better on
the clock some five minutes ahead now
after G F captors and g7 rook after Sun
g7 and Bishop to e3 preparing bishop to
d4 Khurana stops this immediately c5 and
now cousin spent really really all of
his time he went from nine minutes to a
minute and a half so here he played
Bishop to f4 with a minute and a half on
a clockwork or one I had nine minutes
and it's very interesting probably if he
had more time he might have considered
this Bishop to be one more simply moving
it back preparing c4 and yet again
bringing this bishop to this very strong
diagonal but like I said he spent all of
his time it's only more 31 he still has
to make nine more moves to reach time
control and he plays Bishop to f4 and
it's a good thing that he did because
Khurana was most likely expecting this
and he already had a reply and here
Khurana also had to spend some time to
figure out how to go about this okay
rook to e8
finally Khurana brings this inactive
look from H to e8
nice to e3 prepare
Knight to a5 with a double attack
against the d6 pawn we have looked after
some g1 root characters and you want and
the now rook three six karana brings the
rook to help out with the defense of the
pawn and Carson replies nice to d5
Carson really has to play fast as the
time is really low
we have Knight to f6 allowing this night
to c7 idea but Khurana doesn't mind we
have night to c7 would an attack on the
rook and here rook to e2 was played nice
to be 5 with a double attack against the
d6 pawn and also Carson is attacking the
a 7-point Khurana simply goes back up to
e6 defends the pawn and offers his a 7
point and if Knight captures here then
King to h7 is coming Bishop is coming to
h6 the dark square bishop will get
exchanged and then this h5 point is
really as a liability it will fall
through sooner or later so okay rook to
e6 rook to f1 now by Carlsen we have
King to g8 and now tonight back to c7
attacking Coronas rook once again corona
played rook to e2 we have knight back
the b5 by Carlson and Caruana repeats
rook to e6 knight back to c7 by Carlson
and here this was moved 40 so time
control has been reached players
received additional time and after a
corona played rook to e2 both players
now reach time control and they both of
them left the board as they really
needed to clear their heads it was
really an intensive game and intense
game and Carson was really really
probably most likely angry with himself
that he didn't push for advantage there
because after the game in the interview
with Maryse he said that very soon he
realized that f6 was actually the way to
go not Knight to g4 but okay here Carson
after considering what to play for a
couple of more minutes he played night
to b5 and this this now
qualifies as a threefold repetition of
the position he thought Caruana would
you know call the arbiter and said hey
it's a it's a threefold repetition I
want to you know
ask for a draw but instead rook to e6
was played by Caruana and after Carson
saw us he didn't really know why car
wanna play repeated the move
he went for a fourth repetition instead
of calling the arbiter or asking for a
draw but then at some point as we do
have it here Blair's agreed to a draw
after a threefold repetition you can see
that Carson was not very pleased and you
know everyone was watching checking out
what's going to happen but definitely a
very nice moment for Caruana although it
was a beautiful game and like they
mentioned during the live feed this was
the first time that someone actually
challenged Caruana special defense as
when karana warned the candidates he
actually won three games in the
candidates which to the better of
defense with the black pieces so this is
actually a pretty big big deal someone
did ask in the comments like why would
Carson show off what he what he can do
against the petrov why not save it for
november but there's a lot of psychology
here I mean if if you win this game here
if you don't allow Caruana to you know
get near you which is raiding then that
also will play a part in November it's
not just about saving all the best stuff
you're gonna play in November but yeah
and this brings us to the standings
after round seven there you can see a
corona still in the lead with four and a
half points the sole leader followed by
Grigio chlamydia of Aragon and Carlsen
with four points done with three and a
half which one Anton Amman and Maxine
watch your autograph where's Lisa with
three Hikaru Nakamura with two and a
half and Cara can still in last place
with to draw with two points after
drawing his game today with Sharma media
off so that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it
I'm sure I'm positive cause and didn't
but you know that's just things always
happen when you least expect them and it
was a kind of as he already signalized
that in the confessional booth that you
know he will win this game quite to the
haters I was probably a very disgusting
experience for him that when he realized
that he will not in fact
be winning this game so once again I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Joseph Burnett Alexandra put an
eject never the third Devi Domini Fowler
and Rick Roland for Roland for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
think all for watching and I will see
you soon hopefully with another
interesting video thank you all and
enjoy the rest of your Saturday